i've got 10 minutes catch me up we are
officially on breakup numero 9.
well let's hope it sticks this time
niko's like one of those dementors they
suck the soul out of people through
their faces
maybe i'm making too big a deal out of
this whole monogamous thing it's really
hard to just let him go
the hamster wheel of your addiction to
nico has to be destroyed we would like
you to meet someone say hello to your
new fake boyfriend what christianity you
are now in a relationship across all
social media wait what that's the plan
baby yeah it's getting real homie
i saw the new man on insta good for you
so explain yourself
niko was so angry
and i finally know what it's like to
have a little bit of power
is about to go
i own that man
do you want me to text that back for you
jesus christ troy stay out of my
business
hi welcome
there's a guy he is a chef
you're andrew right so you're finally in
the class you wouldn't know how bad of a
cook i am actually trying to make
breakfast one time and then we ended up
at urgent care
that was you
yeah
he better to cristiano i don't need him
anymore we can't delete cristiano just
yet i got a confidence in singapore oh
okay
please no clapping i'm only a man
i gotta show rafi the real me cristiano
just hit 1.6 million followers do you
think that this might be getting a
little out of hand there's something not
right here
the longer this goes on the worse it
gets i can't just delete him jake he's
not real he's real to me
i'm sure andrew has told you all about
his new boyfriend
he's a philanthropist and renowned human
rights activist he still finds time to
make sweet love to little andrew for
hours on end uh wow
sounds too good to be true it is
you